[音楽]
[拍手]
本当にありがとうございます
[音楽]
結局しないよってあるんです私はこういう
ふうに立ち上がりのあるんですけどそれ
以上に自分
は結構自己肯定感の人ってちょっと諦めて
いただいたりするんですけどでもこういう
舞台に私は今後ともいろんなことを話し
ました中学1年生の頃はあんまり音楽
隊で
素人ながら自分のペースで指揮者を担当し
ますし中学1年の頃は生まれることが多い
という
ことです中学3年の時は小学校の中学と
いうことは公文書にしましたそして高校1
年今年ですね
学年近くこの学園さんがこの近くにある
人気のこのクラ
スの
今日それが発表されるのでよろしくお願い
しますね
やってきたんですけどそれがどうして自分
に自信がないと自分に自信がなくてもそう
いうニュース方法を何だかんでいる獲得
できたからということなので冷たいけど
すれば皆さんも本当に簡単にできるなので
私今回は私がそれは実際の方法を紹介して
皆さんにも自分に自信がないから
自分はどうやったって無理だっ
たような感覚でございます
苦しい話をする必要はないのでただの力が
いて聞いていただければなと思います
よろしくお願いします
遅くなりましたがここで自己紹介させて
ください私は国際学園高等学校1216誰
かを求めます今から16年と3ヶ月ぐらい
前に東京のとある
家は比較的強くなれるんですけどそれ以上
にちょこちょこ子どもだけなんですね
父とあればスターウォーズは
SF作品
が大好きですし日本語の声優さんとか
ハリウッドの俳優さんとか女優さん大好き
ですこれでえっとこの話がちゃんとするん
ですか
[音楽]
いつもフェレットで働くタイミングもよく
見てました
オリジナルブランドに関してはいろんな
生き物が
飾られていて声のってせっかくキラキラし
てたものなのでこういう格安に憧れて進行
を目指したテーブルになったのかなと思い
ますそれが結構物語ってますよね
だから正月に年齢
[音楽]
何でもないのが一番楽しかったって言っ
たら気持ちがいるからです
か
大丈夫そうですね
今はもう本当のことだったんですけど
ちょっとぐらいはめちゃくちゃ嫌いだった
んですよ
それってすごく作品で自己中なんですけど
発表
疑惑あるんですけど自分が目立つ機会とも
あまりなかったと思う
例えば運動会のとか
文化祭でのクラスの発表
とかそういうのって大体学年で一丸となっ
て発表するんですけどそれでも自分の
目指せることにはなくてだから自分で
目立っちゃいけない人間なのかなって思っ
たりやっても意味ないんじゃないかなって
思っ
ちゃったじゃあ他の世代を使ってるの私は
もちろん考えましたそれで私は学校の
マーチング番組とか
クラス
の場合は本当に仕事のやりがいないし
憧れ目立たないしで
マーチング番組に関しては一番目立たせる
指揮者になれるっていうのが将来的に約束
されてたんですでもちょっと中学受験勉強
が可能にして私は指揮者にならない
そうだよ結構私の中での生活っていうのが
でそういう学芸員が
マーチングバングっていうのがだいたい
小学3年目ですけどじゃあ1年生の時は
どうやったら選ぶのはもちろんそれは
それが保護者の方にとって一番発想的なん
じゃないでしょうか
[音楽]
このスタンスも14年っていうのは今と
なっては表示しております
[音楽]
一番の原因は中学受験だったりそれに関連
した新しいちょっと
幼馴
[音楽]
小学6年5月っていうタイミングで建国し
たの
にこの戦略先と前の
それぐらいでだいたい受験ちょっとずつ
積み重ねてそれを見直さないというのが
結構主流だと思うんだけどこのちょっと
ずつなんか生まれたこと言えなかっ
たと思われてそしたら他の知識への虐殺で
という
ループがいて成績下がってるところだった
んですか
そういったルートに巻き込まれてそこに
下がってくるようだったって
[音楽]
幼馴
染私がどういう状況でどういう風に考えて
いるのかってもう理解してくれないことへ
の変化も
特徴
一緒に誰も
出てこないで本当にみんなが第一高校に
するという流れになってたんです私は
世間の機会が出てしまうかというだけで
自分が必要それだけじゃなく
[音楽]
私がどういうふうに流れているのかって
いうのを知らずに
ただただ成績が下がっていくとこしか見て
なかったっていうのがありますよねだから
そこから私は
富士に情報を持っていないまま勝手に
イメージをつけるとどうしても自分より
できちゃうだけ
だって場合によってはそれを
自分とか
傷つけることになるんじゃないかって考え
たんですだから私はそれに対してどういう
ふうにアプローチするかというと普通に
本当簡単で情報を集めるだけですよ
どういうことをできるのかって知るだけな
んですか
[音楽]
それに対して私はどういうことですか
絶対に落ちる学生になった自信なかった
から交代し
たい
からインパクトある
で都会への面白いことを調べて
めちゃくちゃで
探してで今日はいらないっていう
対応してテンプレートの順番を変えて自己
紹介の後に私はあなたはいらないって言っ
て
スキルっていうのは少しだけ必要なん
だって
決め手じゃないですかちょっとしたことの
一つでだから傷つい
傷つかないようにするっていうのが大事な
んですけど僕だったら
傷つく
ことを見たら
言った方がいいんじゃない
からそれは
私はなんか笑ってますからそういうのがい
てちょっとあの忘れた方がいいんじゃない
かなっていうふうに
思います左手はされるって方法でおすすめ
は
負ける限り
11月24日よろしくお願いします
最後ですね
自分とか自分のことやりたいっていう
気持ちを否定しないだけ
です
人間って
[音楽]
私の
クラスメイト的な言葉がいっぱい
取れてきたから
さっき私にこのクラス
本当に生活しなくなって絶対に嫌だ
頼まれるだろう
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
とまずはどういうことができるのかなった
のかって情報を
後はこっちのが
あんまりこれやりたいって思う個別のこと
気づいたり
気づいたらその傷が早く戻せるようになっ
てるっていう
すっごい長々しく
答えたでしょうか
お会いできる機会があった感想とかスキル
に対してどう思うことを使ってるかどう
いうことができたかという話を聞けたら
どこかでお会いできたら今日の感想とか
どう思うとか
スキルを使ってみてこういうことができた
よ
そういう言葉で本当に励みになるので言葉
に溢れた世界からあなたにお待たせしまし
たありがとうございました
[拍手]